when this quarantine time is over what
is the first thing you're gonna go out
in the world and do pray no I know I I
don't I don't need to cram bathe in his
blood I also miss feeling famous
well hello how's quarantine treating you
it's doing so good I just I think I'm
built for this I mean obviously I'm
disappointed about my tours being all
rescheduled all my tourists have been
rescheduled at 2021 but it's like it's
not like it's cancellation it's a
reschedule so once I got over that it
was like fall what can I control so it's
like I can sell makeup I can make videos
I can record demos and write music
there's a million ways for me I mean
think about it the hour I spent on stage
is nothing compared to the amount of
work around that so in a lot of ways
it's business as usual except for being
homebound instead of on a tour bus I was
gonna say I know you're a capitalist so
I was wondering how now I'm a capitalist
and bit cheated I am a capitalist for
sure I mean that's the Trixie Mattel way
is like we really find a way to sell
anything and I mean luckily for my
cosmetics company people might be locked
in their houses but people are still
Moore's like people are still buying
mass amounts of like clown makeup which
is wonderful um and then also people are
still listening to my music and watching
my streams and support my youtube
channel it's been great and my movie is
on Netflix right now because everyone's
home moving parts has been under popular
Netflix for like four weeks now I think
every living person has seen it at this
point so maybe quarantine is the best
time to be Trixie Mattel quarantine
Aguilera when you drag name I know you
have an issue saying a soft hello what
is your zoom or video chat hello like oh
she said hi oh it's essential hi it's
sensual it's very sensual yeah
are you quarantined with the boyfriend
are you all alone what's happening oh he
comes over like he'll come and stay for
like five days and then go back to his
house for like four days we try to not
do too much like back and forth um but
he was just here for like five days and
then now I'll probably be home alone for
like a week and I try to fill them all
he's gotta do my
two videos make Beauty videos stuff like
that um but we have the internet
FaceTime and like we still talk all the
time I was gonna see if it was testing
the relationship in any way but it seems
like that's also business as usual we've
been together like almost four years so
like this isn't if we had just started
dating and then it was like I love you I
wish you were together all the time
because our love is magic and our kisses
create smiles you know like we've been
together long enough it's like we're
just come over next week for sex and
then you know then we then we can you
like not see each other for like five
days
one leg off one week on yeah it's like
I'm divorced parents yeah besides that
they I guess a lot of relationships are
gonna be tested by this but we don't
live together because I'm not um crazy
do you live with your boyfriend I do
he's I relegated him to the other room
to film do you feel weird because that's
like me too I feel weird when he's here
I'm like if I'm gonna do a stream or
something I'm like you can't be here you
need to go yeah no we're going in and
out like he has zoom calls too so it's
like we just switched spaces all day
long
it's real fun yeah you look beautiful
have you been doing a lot of zoom I mean
if you could see the light the light I
mean I'm ready
oh you're ready for the apocalypse comes
you'll still be putting out content I
know well luckily we were doing you know
my YouTube channel stuff so like I
already had lights and and microphones
and cameras and all that so like when
this happened and luckily I was already
doing streams from time to time so I
already had a good grasp on the
streaming software so like you know I
don't have to be the drag queen on
iPhone three in the dark holding a
camera at this level with no big on
being like please spend money I get to
give a little more fantasy yeah we um we
chat it was shangela the other day and
she has had a bear light like a lamp
with the shade off right in front of her
blasting her house she lights like she
says and though I know the traditional
industry has been hit hard how can we
support drag artists at
time well the drag queen is you know
giving you a [ __ ] in a car drive slow
you don't need to take those pipe turns
does not proper social distancing well
what I mean to walk there's drag shows
every all the time now on all levels I
mean if you want to get online the other
night that caught Sonique from drag race
in like a bikini lip-syncing on
Instagram live in her bedroom I mean
there's that level there's high
production but think about it your tweet
your boat your mailing list your venmo
dollar there's a million ways to be
supportive so even if you're just
showing up to a stream or just tweeting
it should retweet it like everything you
do helps and honestly most drag queens
at our hearts I don't think everybody is
as hard a corporate capitalist as me
most people are doing it because they
love it and so if you love their work
you can support them we can also tune in
to RuPaul's secret celebrity drag race
starting Friday which you're gonna be a
part of yes I am welcome to RuPaul's
secret celebrity drag race full of star
transformations so glad worthy Julie to
see it to believe it I know originally
it was just called a drag race and then
I came and they called it celebrity drag
race but I will say I will say most of
these performers the great thing is they
are you know singers actors
personalities they are performers in
some way and so the transformative power
of makeup and costumes and hair it's not
new to them and there is something about
like when you look different you perform
different and so for celebrities it ends
up being sort of a it ended up being a
language with her like I can't speak it
but I understand it you know what I mean
what they do kinda hiccup quickly but I
will say uh you know for the first time
we saw it celebrities putting on but I
this is why Bri I mentored when I saw
ahead and pick up that makeup brush I
knew I was like I didn't even need to
see the brush on the face I was like
just the way he held it like like
like a death grip like alright that's
what's fun about it is I don't want to
watch drag race where everything
everyone's good at everything I want to
see brought enthusiasm transformed into
surprising talent you know
yeah so breakdown how the show works
because we know very little about it all
we've seen is that little like 30 second
teaser each week non-professional drag
queen who happen to be widely known
celebrities have chosen to come compete
on drag race in iconic drag race style
challenges impersonations dancing
singing musicals they're actually doing
challenges very similar to what
professional drag queens are doing and
they're having to do it like drop of a
hat
you just started wearing a wig yesterday
now you're on the main stage in front of
RuPaul in front of TV and God doing this
and so the celebrities while they do
have sort of an incentive to win like um
financially like for charity and stuff a
lot of them actually have kind of a
personal reason for being there which
kind of makes it better because a lot of
them have something they're looking to
gain from this experience obviously they
all wanted the the masses of drag race
to find out like here's my Twitter
whatever but they actually all have like
I was really surprisingly touched like
the celebrity that I worked with who got
really close and I was like I had no
idea you were here to like get all that
from this I spent a lot of time of day
people and I not always the most
comfortable around like straight people
and it was a learning experience for me
too
I didn't expect to go there and like you
will laugh and you will cry let's just
say that it's a surprisingly touching
show I was looking to ask why guys
tricked me into having feelings on
television again what surprised you
about it so it was that how kind of
grounded it was I guess yes because on
the first day it's very like it's gonna
be a great time we're all gonna have a
great time by that by the end of their
training experience in their performance
I'm in
bested I am invested in drag queens are
nothing if not competitive and so like
us as mentors we're sort of like aren't
they great but it is like that is my
daughter on the swim team and if she
doesn't win I will let the air out of
your tires like so we are very invested
and and then make the Queen's the the
new drag queens they're obviously trying
to win money for their you know
philanthropic endeavors but also they're
trying to like learn something about
themselves from the experience and they
actually do and it's actually very
touching today to being back in that
space make you like want to compete
again at all are you happy to be in this
mentor role now the best thing about
being on drag race this time was knowing
nothing bad was gonna happen to me Tracy
Martel it was like finally this is the
insurance policy I wanted the whole time
which is like nothing Bad's gonna happen
to me
I don't love that um I really really
liked that about the experience it's
like I get to be in the culture without
having to like you know Namine like look
over my shoulder cuz I'm not I'm not
very not a great competitor some people
competition brings out the best in them
for me it maybe doesn't always bring out
the best um so but though a lot of the
other mentors are there's a lot of
really competitive really good drug-free
mentors and you know we all approach
things differently I'm a little more
hands-on with people like if I want
someone to know what it feels like to
get in drag I need to start putting in a
drag I want to see the hair the jewelry
the costume like to me once you're in it
you feel it and then you can do it okay
so we're gonna see different styles of
stage mom oh yeah someone let's star a
little more Eat Pray Love somewhat buffs
are a little more like you're gonna do
it I'm telling you do it right you know
so
which I got really invested I'm not
gonna lie I got really invested it's
definitely that stage mom thing - of
like the mentors watching them perform
gripping each other's hands you can hear
the bones breaking like you know serious
I'm excited to see it and it's paired
right up with season 12 which is a
little more I think like halfway ish
through how are you feeling about season
12 who are you keeping an eye on well I
mean I'm from Milwaukee and Jada and I
have been doing drag since we were both
like 20 so like Jane and I are been go
really used to come shop for makeup at
my makeup counter when I worked at the
Mac counter so like we've gone we've
gotten really far back and it's hard to
really see anybody beating her because
she's good at everything and always and
literally I'm not kidding Jada has
looked like this
since she like came out of the box
there's been no improvement she's been
this beautiful forever forever she's
been the most beautiful drag queen
walking forever so and I feel like she's
playing a good game cuz she's kind of
she's not under the radar but she's kind
of like right at the radar yeah she's
not Lenny waves yet she's not like
cheating out on the couch and like going
for storyline and she's not like you
know I mean she's not playing the game
too hard yeah and she her voice is so
funny to me I mean she just has such a
like chat out like a really like child
every other word and very endearing
she's a very endearing speaking voice
totally know I've enjoyed watching her
alright to wrap things up here when this
quarantine time is over what is the
first thing you're gonna go out in the
world and do
pray know um I know I I don't I don't
need to cram bathe in his blood
um but also I would like to go to the
Gold's because the day before the
quarantine I left my house keys at the
Gold's so had been ever locked my door
nobody robbed me as an Gold's Gym the
Gold's Gym my house keys are there
they're like what are your keys look
like I said it's a pink keychain with a
bunch of little Barbie dolls on it and
it has a tamagotchi on it and they're
like we can't find it so I know that's
not like relatable content but I'll
probably go there and also um whenever
I'm home I'm used to going out with my
boyfriend we go to dinner a lot so like
I miss going to Hugo's in kitchen 24 and
the conservatory in West Hollywood I
miss going to drag shows and generally I
just miss going out to the game art and
watching drag queens and getting drunk
is that sad I'm 30 your first order of
business is just be gay when you get out
yeah I also miss so spread that around
the world yeah yeah I miss feeling
famous I miss going places and have
people recognize me like I'm gonna go to
like the Apple Store forever 21 all the
gay hotspots to get noticed when this is
over those are the gay hotspot to the
Apple Store forever 21 completely yeah
in the Mac counter yeah I'm gonna go to
the Grove and just like wear tight jeans
and stand there and wait for people as
therapy sounds like the perfect plan
okay well thanks for making the time to
talk to us good - Ingrid barley see you
all right bye
Oh stopped by a soft sensual vibe yes
essential bye
[Music]